I've got some advice from some top-notch
people here used to speaking to crowds
the vice president said tap your glass
there spoon against your glass and
senator Stephen said just go like this
Shh friends and colleagues I'd like to
thank just a brief but take just a brief
moment this evening to let you know of
the work that your executive committee
of the RTC a does year in and year out
on your behalf
many of you may think of this committee
is the entity that puts on this dinner
every spring and certainly it is the
highlight of the season for all of us
here in this room tonight but the
committee does much more performing
duties that have a direct impact on the
ability of each of you to cover our
national legislature who is eligible to
be credentialed for example the
committee also has fought for your right
to access to our nation's leaders in the
halls of the Capitol defended your right
to privacy in the credentialing of
special events and most recently worked
with the Capitol authorities to expand
camera access to the Capitals corridors
the committee does all this with a
dedicate dedication to the idea that yes
our viewers and listeners have a right
to know what is happening in their
national legislature and to the notion
that information wants to be free and
with that I'd like to introduce to you
our head table this evening starting
from my far left and your far right a
man who has seen and done it all in the
world of press communications and
political communications in Washington
he is now the speakers director of
communications our friend Ron bond gene
Ron
you know Charles DeGaulle once said that
there's no such thing as an
indispensable person but Charles de
Gaulle never met Tina tape the director
of the house radio and television gala
Lee Ann McBride is the vice president's
press secretary and she's with us
tonight welcome Leanne next is the one
they call shaggy the next chairman of
this committee mr. Steve cigars of CBS
News
next is the House Democratic whip the
Honorable Steny Hoyer from the fifth
District of a great team player for this
committee is Heather Dahl of Capitol
news connection the House Majority Whip
the Honorable Roy Blunt of Missouri is
here a good friend she's wonderful and
very smart
Andrea Seabrook of National Public Radio
good luck with that and the majority
leader of the United States Senate dr.
bill first of Tennessee my dear friend
of one of the best journalists I know
Ted Barrett of CNN
with your indulgence mrs. Cheney I'd
like to come back to you in a moment
next is the current chairman of this
committee and a man to be reckoned with
Brian Wilson of Fox News mr. vice
president if I may come back to you as
well and I'm going to start down on your
far left and my far right
mic mastery on is the director of the
Senate radio and television gallery it
seems like a long time ago when Susan
Dryden whitson was on the house side to
the first lady longtime Senate
communications wizard and now spokesman
for dr. frist is Bob Stevenson I'm very
happy and pleased that Linda Kenyon from
Salem radio network is here with us this
evening Linda the Senate Majority Whip
is here with a senator Mitch McConnell
of Tennessee a woman who kept me on my
toes during my tenure as chairman of
this committee miss Ellen Schwager of
c-span
please welcome the gentlelady from
California and the House Democratic
Leader Nancy Pelosi ladies and gentlemen
the majority leader may no no longer be
the hammer but we have the nail in the
house Brian Miller of National Public
Radio please welcome the pros president
pro temporary of the United States
Senate and the chairman of the Senate
Commerce science and Transportation
Committee Ted Stevens of Alaska and
sitting to the vice president's
immediate right is the vivacious Annie
tin of c-span and finally we welcome
back once again this year the vice
president and mrs. Cheney mr. vice
president
mrs. Cheney we thank you for your
gracious attendance and your support of
this dinner over the last five years now
ladies and gentlemen if I could ask you
to once again rise for our toast and
tonight we do have a two-parter first
our traditional toast to the vice
president and mrs. Cheney and the men
and women of the 109th Congress salute
and ladies and gentlemen tonight let us
also toast to the memory of the brave
men and women of our profession who over
the past year have paid the ultimate
price in pursuit of the truth and
performing their duty to the public
may their memory never fade ladies and
gentlemen please be seated
ladies and gentlemen oh I'm not gonna
lose your attention now ladies and
gentlemen since we last gathered we have
lost a giant of our profession for more
than 40 years Peter Jennings made all of
us proud to be journalists his passing
in August from lung cancer was a
devastating loss for our colleagues at
ABC News but I think each and every one
of us in this room can't feel but help
but feel the void that he has left
behind we asked our friends at ABC News
to prepare a tribute to Peter Jennings
for this dinner and so here is mr.
Jennings in his own words reminding us
of why we honor him today
it doesn't matter whether on the anger
where the editor once a reporter always
a reporter and once a reporter you
always understand the stories are
essentially about people and that the
best way to tell other people about
what's happening is through the lives
and the attitudes of people you
encounter I think that all of us who
work in our newsrooms
believe all the time that there are
ethics and and rules very often
unwritten by which we should live and
they have to do with responsibility and
they have to do with getting it right
and being fair I like doing what I'm
doing because it is always an adventure
I'm always going somewhere somewhere in
the country somewhere at a neighborhood
some are overseas somewhere to a
neighborhood overseas I'm sometimes
referred to as a street side writer by
my colleagues because I sometimes do my
best writing sitting on the sidewalk
long before I've ever got back to the
newsroom I tend to focus very hard under
pressure which I think serves a
journalist or an anchorperson pretty
well but I have indeed lost it on
television both in large and small ways
when President Reagan went to comfort
the families of the astronauts who died
I lost it completely I almost lost it a
couple of times on 9/11 most
specifically when I turned around to
find that my children had called from
two parts of the country to reassure me
that they were okay and I think it made
me think of a lot of families and their
children but I think it's important to
keep it together if we don't keep it
together at a time of crisis who's going
to I lived in the Middle East for a long
time and I the one thing I learned after
living there was that there is no one
absolutely essential truth for all
people and that every time I look at a
coin I would instinctively one look at
the other side I get up every day
thinking that something is going to
happen in the world that I didn't know
about yesterday and I have the
opportunity to pass some
that on to the audience I get up every
day knowing that I can learn or
understand something better and that it
is my job to do so the people will pay
me to do that in order to help people
understand the environment in which we
live I that's fabulously exciting the
wonder we're passionate would be nuts if
we didn't like that
thank you ABC News for compiling them
now comes a particularly important part
to the evening when we present the the
Joan Shorenstein Barone award and then
the David bloom award the Barone award
is presented for excellence in
Washington based reporting for national
affairs and public policy here to tell
us about Joan Barone and to present the
award is bill Plante of CBS News bill
they didn't gentlemen good evening this
award honors Jones memory in her career
at CBS News she went from researcher
where some of you probably are tonight
to executive producer of Face the Nation
and his why this award means something
getting it says that the winner has
shown the kind of enterprise and style
and smarts for which her colleagues
always admired Joan she was demanding
very demanding but she was also generous
one researcher now a producer here who
worked for her during the 1984
convention that the Democrats had in San
Francisco tells the story of staying up
all night on a project for her and being
greeted in the morning with that's not
what I wanted but then being surprised
the same day by an offer of a ticket to
a box seat at Candlestick Park for the
all-star game that night she had the
kind of high-standards that the critics
say don't exist anymore
in the kind of work we do but the
winners of this award are proof that
those standards do exist
Joan wasn't just smart and tough she was
that but she was a good friend to many
of us as well someone who enjoyed life
who loved politics the kind of person
that you would wish had been at your
table tonight so it is with great
pleasure that on behalf of the radio
television Correspondents Association we
announce the winner of this year's Joan
Shorenstein Barone award chad pilgrim of
capitol news connection
- correspondent for Capital News
connection Chad program spent 2005
digging into the details of backroom
deals late night votes and consuming
issues like war and terrorism but he
even found time to explore the alleged
lighter side of Capitol Hill listeners
of some 200 public radio outlets across
the country heard Chad's daily reports
in which among other things he
anticipated the rise of John Boehner as
House Majority Leader and faunal
congressman Stephen law to read on his
agonizing path toward the casting of the
decisive votes on free trade and budget
legislation chad programs
up-to-the-minute reporting symbolizes
the kind of Capitol Hill coverage the
John Shorenstein award was created to
conquer and we are pleased to confer
this honor on him tonight
well I guess what I'll say is that the
images I saw a few minutes ago from
Peter Jennings are really the reason I
got in to the news business I was 18
years old and I started to intern at a
radio station in Cincinnati when I was
still in high school this is an ABC
Radio affiliate WKRC in Cincinnati not P
and I really admired the reports I would
hear from from Jennings he would do some
some some pieces here and there and I
said you know that's the type of
journalist I want to be and in watching
those images of Jennings if I could only
be a sliver of what he does and his
legacy and that all of us here tonight
can carry on in our reporting whatever
field were in whatever beat we have here
in Washington or around the country
remember Peter Jennings and I often
think of him even though I never worked
at ABC News I have a lot of respect from
him for him I was in New York this past
summer the day he died and I went down
to ABC News and there's a little bus
stand close to the bureau there and
people had put sort of a a small
memorial out there sort of a makeshift
memorial much like they did and the
bridge across where Princess Diana died
and people had put up memories and
flowers and so on and I said that's the
type of journalist I'd like to be and
for those of you here tonight I think if
you remember the legacy of Jennings and
we try to do what Jennings did the world
would be a little better thank you
and congratulations Chad this year we
want to welcome once again to the dinner
John Brown's father Walter Shorenstein
mr. Schwartz team they're very pleased
that you could join us this evening
thank you sir
great to see you every year here now
comes a moment that has special
resonance for me and many of my
colleagues and NBC News tonight we
present the third annual David bloom
award for excellence and Enterprise
investigative or feature reporting and
with us tonight for the first time to
present the award named after their
father our Christine and Nicole bloom
David and Melanie's 12-year old twins
they're here to give the award ladies
our father David bloom passed away three
years ago while covering the war in Iraq
we loved him very much and we miss him
and we are proud of the hard and
dedicated work he did but tonight we are
not just thinking about our dad we are
also thinking about the other soldiers
and journalists who have and are risking
their lives for us throughout the world
we keep them all in our thoughts and
prayers and remember the hard work they
are doing for us the David bloom award
was created to honored daring Enterprise
reporters who show investigative skills
and bravery under difficult
circumstances we are thrilled to
announce that this year's winner of the
David bloom award as Bob Woodruff
bob is one of our families and our dad's
best friends as you know bob was injured
by covering the war in Iraq our prayers
are with him for a speedy recovery this
is what the judges said about the
competition this year quote the
competition for the award was very
intense and the committee wishes to
extend a special award of recognition to
CNN reporter gene misery
her coverage of Hurricane Katrina
revealed genes extraordinary composure
and compassion as well as her unwavering
respect for the facts and colorful
details that make for a great
storytelling under exceedingly difficult
circumstances the judges wrote quote in
2005 there was no reporter whose work
was more perfectly embody the spirit of
the award than this year's winner Bob
Woodruff David bloom gave His life
reporting from Iraq and Bob nearly lost
his life in the same theater but
sentimentality played no role in the
judging of this competition in fact Bob
submission did not include any of his
reporting from Iraq rather the award was
decided on the basis of Bob's peerless
and enterprise reporting which took him
last year to the capital cities of two
of the world's most secretive and brutal
regimes North Korea and Iran and his
courageous coverage of Hurricane Katrina
end quote
congratulations to Bob Woodruff of ABC
News
tonight on Bob's behalf is Martha
Raddatz with ABC News
father wanted me to accept this for him
and it means an enormous amount that he
wanted me to do that he has a statement
he would like me to read he also did not
want me to cry although he did not want
me to cry very much so I've read it
several times so hopefully I won't cry
at all but we'll see about that Bob says
I am so honored to accept the David
bloom award not only because David was a
true friend and respected colleague but
because of what the award means David
was so many things an avid competitor on
the tennis court as well as a worthy
competitor in the field he had an
enthusiasm for every story that was
infectious
he also loved his family fiercely as you
know he was so very proud of his three
little girls and his wife Melanie
Chrissy Nicole and little Ava out in the
audience I wish that I were here in
person to accept this award and give you
a giant hug all the way to the sky just
like we always do I am so honored that
you have adopted me into your family as
a surrogate uncle we'll be jumping on
the trampoline together again I promise
one thing that David and I shared was
our belief that in order to really cover
a story you need to be out in the field
you need to talk to the men and women
who are shaping the story who are part
of the events unfolding David and I
remarked all the time that we could not
believe someone would actually pay us to
do this job I know so many of you in
this room share that sentiment and I am
honored to be counted among you as a
colleague
last year I covered some amazing stories
all over the world in places like Iran
and North Korea and in our own country
with the tragedy of Katrina though I am
the person the audience sees now as
always I want to underscore that I am
just one of a team that people who
helped to save Doug's in my life inside
the tank in January venom O Hara and
Magnus Macedo are the same dedicated men
who have traveled with me on so many
stories and they have always had my back
my entire focus right now is on my
family and my recovery and getting back
to doing the
job I so love but please invite me back
next year
I'd love to raise a glass with you all
to life
I also want to add that Bob and Lee
wanted me to talk about the US military
Bob and Lee both said they could not
love the people more who helped save
save Bob's life from the initial
incident to getting him out of Iraq
quickly to caring for him at Bethesda
Naval Hospital we think we thank them
all
so looking forward to someday Bob being
back with us at ABC thank you and thank
you on behalf of Bob
the judges for both the Verona and bloom
Awards this year were mr. Vic Ratner of
ABC News James Rosen of Fox News and
Deirdre Walsh of CNN the committee
thanks them for their integrity and
their enthusiasm
now ladies and gentlemen at the risk of
sounding a little bit like Ed Sullivan
I'd like to recognize someone in our
crowd tonight a brand new champion
representing the United States of
America
she is the New World Figure Skating
champion won at last saturday in calgary
alberta miss Kimmie Meissner is with us
ladies and gentlemen is my question now
to introduce the president of the Senate
a man who also happens to be vice
president of the United States please
give a warm welcome to Vice President
Dick Cheney
thank you very much obvious this is very
moving tribute this evening to three men
Peter Jennings Bob Woodruff and David
bloom who represent the very best of
your profession were all much much
better off as a nation for the
tremendous contribution they've made
over the years and the professionalism
and the dedication they've shown is
reflected in the awards here tonight
Lynn and I are delighted to be with you
this evening the president of course is
on his way to Cancun
when Lynn and I've been looking forward
to filling in and we deeply appreciate
your hospitality I've got to admit that
I was a little startled by the size and
the diversity of the crowd tonight when
I agreed to do this I was still hey
don't worry about it they'll all be from
Fox
actually I'm feeling pretty comfortable
up here the lighting could be better
you'll see the whites of your eyes
Scott McClellan was the one who told me
I should accept your invitation and I
guess you could say that I owed Scott a
favor he insisted that I actually show
up and deliver these remarks I said hell
why not just post them in the Corpus
Christi collar times
but it was Scots thinking that by coming
here I could improve my relations with
the press corps you know do a little
bridge building so let's go to work on
this bridge to nowhere
tonight I won't play favorites all at
once and at the same time the assembled
Washington press corps is going to have
a look behind the scenes because I
brought along some pictures so let's
kill the lights and begin the slideshow
people in the news media have been
concerned lately about the NSA
surveillance program you don't need to
worry about that I can assure you that
the wiretapping is conducted by trained
professionals people who know exactly
what they're looking for and exactly how
to use it
of course I'm a busy man and I can't be
expected to listen in on all of your
private conversations sometimes I just
review the transcripts with a little
help from my senior advisor for
wiretapping
another controversy this month was the
big debate over the Dubai ports deal
it's all been worked out now but if I
may say I'm a little bit disappointed
Don Rumsfeld is - we had already
organized an elite port security strike
force and even given it a trial run
I really like working with Don Rumsfeld
and as most of you know he and I go back
a long way here we are here we are in
1975 with our boss President Gerald Ford
in the Oval Office that's down on the
left and me on the right back back when
I carried a comb here's a typical
picture of Don and me listening to
President Ford this next one taken just
last summer is a typical picture a
present for it and me listening to Don
as many of you know my first job in the
executive branch was back as an
assistant to Don Rumsfeld in 1969 and I
cannot shake the feeling to this day
that Don still sees me as an underling
so recently in the Oval Office I asked
the president himself to explain to Don
that the Secretary of Defense does not
outrank the vice president the United
States here's how Don took the news
I have learned not to take friends like
Don for granted especially in recent
days with all this crazy talk
about my being frozen out at the White
House nothing could be further from the
truth
oh I suppose if I were the insecure type
I might read too much into things for
example just the other day I went in to
see the president at our usual time hmm
he must have been delayed somehow but I
figured he'd be along any minute after
an hour after an hour so I figured I'd
better hurry along to our next appoint
but a crucial one in the Situation Room
and then it was time for lunch with the
cabinet and I sure didn't want to miss
that it's been like this a lot lately at
the White House
but I can assure you that my standing is
not in doubt
I really do spend a lot of time every
day with the most powerful man in
Washington
so powerful in fact that he inserted
that line in my remarks one of the
political jobs that Carl counts on me to
do is to get out there and work our base
this assignment hasn't done much to
soften my image so lately I've been
looking for some advice
the President himself said one thing you
can do is get in shape
get your gear and join me on the bike
trail so as you'll see in these next two
slides off we went with the president in
the lead
the president also took me out on the
Tureaud to give me some tips for one
thing he said when lots of people are
waving at you you've got to show some
reaction and yawning doesn't count Scott
McClellan has been giving me advice too
he told me to rethink my whole approach
to the news media and I guess he's onto
something here's how Scott gets himself
ready to meet the press corps and here's
how I've been doing it
I've also gotten some good advice as
always for my wife Lynn she's a scholar
and a best-selling author she's done
several children's books including a
very charming and successful primer
entitled a is for Abigail I thought I'd
try a children's story myself but Lynn
didn't care much for my first draft of B
is for bunker-buster Lynn also told me
to be a little more sociable but I know
how to have fun
nobody parties like me this next shot
was taken in my recent birthday bash
when I could feel myself almost losing
control
another of Lin's helpful suggestions was
that I go out and find myself a pal
a buddy like President Bush has somebody
who can really laugh it up with now I
like how the president has bonded with
his new buddy Bill Clinton so I thought
I'd try something like that myself
that didn't work out so great and for
some reason that escapes me things
didn't get much better with Senator
Leahy
I thought for sure Karl Rove would be my
buddy so I asked him if he wanted to go
hunting but you know I can always count
on two special buddies my dogs Jackson
and Dave they've taught me to see the
world in black and white my dogs will
never be as famous as the president's
dogs Barney and miss beezly live in the
White House and they get all the
attention but I guarantee you this my
dog Dave is the only dog in America who
knows how to wink before we turn the
evening over to the real comedian Frank
Caliendo I suppose I should deal with
one final matter it came up the other
day when I was on Face the Nation with
Bob Schieffer it's this whole business
about how the White House staff is
exhausted and worn out i downplayed the
situation a bit with Bob but there might
be something to this rumor after all
fortunately ladies and gentlemen the
president knows there's one guy in the
West Wing who's as chipper as ever happy
to be right where he is and still at the
top of his game so I'll leave you with a
smile and thank you for a good evening
thank you very much mr. vice president
our next speaker is a great talent and
up-and-comer in the world of
entertainment you've seen him on MADtv
and Fox NFL Sunday please welcome mr.
Frank Caliendo
thank you guys for clapping almost all
the way till I got up here I feel like I
need to bloom twins boxes to stand on
it's amazing to be here it really is I'm
originally from a little suburb of
Chicago Milwaukee and my whole career
has been based on doing voices of other
people it's pretty interesting uh I
started out with one impression that's
really gotten people to know me John
Madden the football announcer some
people don't like him I love John Madden
because he makes me feel smart he tells
you things you already know he doesn't
give you any new information just sit
there with the NFL SKU doodles or on
circles on guys body parts John man will
say things like the quarterback if he
throws the ball is and the receiver if
he catches it in the endzone is that as
good as that's gonna that events gonna
dividend stirred Escobar well you pou PA
that's gonna that's going to be a
touchdown
even my mom was never watched football
their entire life is going no duh and he
says the same thing in the beginning of
the sentence that he says in the end of
the sentence and I have no idea what
he's doing in the middle then he'll wrap
it up with the words and that's what
that's all about when he says and that's
what that's all about that's a bandaid
on a John Madden tragedy okay because
he'll say things like great football is
about great football if you have great
football players playing great football
that's the best kind of football to play
but you have regular players playing
great football just regular great
football and that's what that's all
about
and that's what that's all about fresh
leads me to believe he'd be great at the
hokey-pokey
you know John man's probably in this bus
somewhere right now just practicing you
put your right foot and you take your
right foot out you put your right foot
and you shake it all about you do the
Hokey Pokey and you turn yourself from
Pope and that's what that's all about
and I think he would be a great I was
thinking about this just for this
audience because I think it would be a
great speaker for the White House
because if you ever asked him a question
like what what do you think's going on
with the war on terror well I think that
we have to do things that we do and when
we do those things other things happen
and when the things happen that you
don't want to happen you've got to go
back and they tell me what made that
happen is then you gotta say hey we
can't let that happen again
as you know football he loves this one
player Brett Farr if you don't know who
Brett Favre is that's the guy from the
end of their Something About Mary and he
loves Brett Farr I don't know what it is
maybe because it sounds so good when he
says like Brett Favre
it just sounds perfectly I'm waiting for
the day where he doesn't interview with
he talks about him so much waiting for
the day where John Madden doesn't nearly
interview with Brett was like Brett I
wrote you a poem I hope you'll like it
roses are red violets are blue I might
like football but I love you I mean he
talks about Brett Favre for no reason at
all you know it's like somebody made a
bet with him said you can't work Brett
Favre and everything son of a gun I
can't watch this he's like and one day
you say about hybrid grass like half of
that grass on the field is real and half
of it is fake but Brett Favre is all
real you owe me 50 bucks right Favre is
the greatest player in the world both
his eyeballs like it would still be the
best torso in football that's how good
Brett Favre a bread flour you throw a
football 200 yards underwater I came to
throw football one yard under worth 200
minus one that's a hundred 99 more yards
Brett Favre can throw a football
underwater and he can hit any target he
wants that's why you put Brent Favre in
Afghanistan Boop he did Osama bin Laden
but the Packers don't want to get rid of
Brett Farr they need Brett Farr because
Brett Favre is the Brett Favre of Brett
Favre inist and without Brett Favre they
wouldn't have Brett Farr and that's what
that's all about
it's it now uh recently I got a chance
to uh to be on the David Letterman Show
and this this video that I did has ended
up all over the internet and I'm I'm a
fan of President Bush I always have been
I thank you uh that's the Fox News
people there today the I don't know
listen the year hear me out on this I I
do like him I for a couple of reasons I
think he sticks by what he believes in
and secondly I think it's great we have
a president who seems like he's always
looking directly into the Sun
cuz I might do me a favor and hand me a
pair of sunglasses somebody get me a
visor sooner you mean advisor no a visor
what you listening man is the only
person our president is the only person
I've ever seen do this move when he
talks
is anybody did anybody do that tonight
like where you going Correspondents
Dinner
nobody does that nobody walked in like
what are you doing man I'm doing
whatever I want it's going to be fun now
I don't mean anything political by this
I don't mean anything about the person I
have seen two other creatures on earth
do that move again nothing political by
this I've seen turkeys do that so every
time I see the president on TV I'm
waiting for him to go gobble gobble so I
wish I had been advising him during the
debate the debates because he he could
have done that all the time cuz John
Kerry would say stuff that would stumble
him a little you make him stumble a
little bit I'd be like mr. president as
your advisor what I want you to do is
just turn him and go gobble gobble
gobble gobble
hey that's a fry flipper I'm a king of
America land of the free and home of the
whopper
gobble gobble whopper whopper that's a
turkey burger be huh unfortunately the
other is a bird too and it's nothing
pigeons do that and I'm thinking if you
could ever get past the Secret Service
with some bread you could throw it down
and there's no way the president walking
by you without going see I like it
mostly when when our president gets
something right because when he gets
something right he is the happiest man
you know he gets that little smile on
his face that I can't believe that came
out correctly smile
it's like a fan is blowing on them two
or three hundred miles an hour and it's
not getting rid of world where the world
hunger is it's just getting all the way
through the sentence and he's content
right be like and that's why the United
States will lead us all to peace
gobble gobble and sometimes cans are way
better than I thought you'd be hey we're
gonna be like when I can all they give
me who open for you Vice President
Cheney and he was good sometimes our
president almost get all the way to the
end of the sentence and he won't be able
to think of that last word and are you
like me you find yourself kind of
rooting for him to get it
he's almost always all the way there and
we've all been there it's happened to
all of us but for him he's got TV
cameras on them all the time it's and
you know you get Michael more than
Notepad 'no cheeseburger watching him
have to make a movie about you and and
unfortunately happens with the easiest
of words of the most inopportune times
right the cameras all over the place to
be talking about something really
serious - that he can't get to talking
about the terrorists be like these
terrorists these guys are wrong guys are
these guys were bad
yeah yeah two choices bad or not good
that just took a little bit too long
please remember I think it started for
everybody the week when the news picked
up on that he would get the sayings
wrong sometimes the that the big one
that one where the during his first term
they went like there's an old saying in
Texas Tommy wants shame on you shame me
how do you think he does this dope stuff
I cannot believe I did that
let's try this again hand up here we go
you ever seen that move this will right
there I think it's a presidential move
any presidents gonna do it at some point
I used to wonder what it was with him
that I realized he's kind of like a slot
machine cuz every time he opens his
mouth he knows he's gambling just a
little bit listen hey I voted for him
twice
all right in each election so people
take a little bit too long to get that
one
fer me once shame on you shame me uh
once twice three times a lady I think he
should do just a suggestion is finish
things with the words the end if I did
that I would always know when I was done
it would be perfect right at first named
for him who once teach the nation a
penny saved is a penny earned be like a
penny saved is a it's once and she put
in your pocket for a while because it's
yours your earned it to the stock market
or not right now but it what turns in
put in there and be you forever and ever
like one of those sideways eight
thingies that means a long time and the
end I forgot to tell you this that
there's another time he does this a lot
is one what he doesn't when he wants to
accentuate a point when he wants to make
sure you're listening we like we must do
this as a country we must do this
together and secondly he does it when he
says a Spanish word
I'd like a burrito look out for the
Cucaracha don't think I could get tired
ordering at Taco Bell
I like a gordita and two tacos por favor
it's Cancun man muy bueno I think about
the differences between presidents too
sometimes because so it's so different
you always hear that President Bush
behind the scenes can just ease a people
have got people golf with them and all
kinds of stuff tell me how nice and
funny is and stuff like that and then
but you look at the persona Clinton was
amazing on television I mean he could
talk his way out of anything well Bill
Clinton could stand here in front of you
look you all directly in the eyes and
say I am NOT here
or not
you do not see me I don't know what it
is you're looking at but it is not May
what is here isn't here just there
without a tea
ladies I love you anything not so for
President Bush he tells the truth and
sometimes it's an accident it just slips
out that's what I like about him he's a
regular guy not Slick Willy if the
Monica Lewinsky scandal happen to
President Bush there's no way gets out
of it not a chance
put him on the stand mr. president you
have relations with that woman Monica
Lewinsky Oh what did they tell me to say
here
that was out loud one
I cannot believe I said that there's two
kinds of words inside words and outside
words inside words staying outside words
come out that time and inside word
popped out
gobble-gobble originally the president I
was told was gonna be here too and I was
kind of hoping for all the house I was
worried at some point he was gonna look
to you mr. Janus go hey Derek Paul
Oh No I think he's just fun to watch I
don't know I just imagine him walking
around the White House going hey boo got
you this game is fun man try this again
hey County boo gotcha
he accidentally walks past a mirror boo
whoa got myself I knew it was coming but
I didn't expect it that situation was
scarify and Scarah fication factor Code
Red one step above Orange Crush two
above mellow yellow' all effective
levels of fat and terror and also tasty
beverages or beverage ace for those of
you who speak español ich I understand
I'm all over the place I go with the
Robin Williams a comedy theory you know
if you don't have a joke just switch
voices there we go okay
see I go off on tangents e here's the
act right here it's a big circle in the
middle what he did was he went off on a
tangent over there you know what a
tangent is a lot of tangerines they're
my favorite fruit like melons the beer
thank you
Thank You Frank Caliendo wonderful thank
you ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen there is a group of
individuals who staff the radio and
television galleries that we rely on
every day to support us and facilitate
our work with the authorities that run
the Capitol and the members of Congress
I would like to recognize them now for
all that they do for us on the house
side working under the direction of
misty notate our Gail Davis
Olga Kornacki Andy Elias J Roper and Kim
Otis
on the Senate side working with mr. Mike
Mastry on our Jane rule Mike Lawrence
sarah robertson and the two newest
staffers in the gallery arlen salazar
and aaron Yeatman your ever planning a
party for two twenty three hundred of
your closest friends I strongly suggest
that you contract the services of miss
Ivan Goldberg who was our dinner
coordinator and back with us again this
year thank you very much Ivan my own
personal dr. Melfi
over the last six weeks or so ladies and
gentlemen there are a few times in a
man's life when he can stand up at
before a crowd of 2,300 and a live
nationwide television audience and thank
his wife and his mother
so by god that's what I'm gonna do right
now my wife Kim is sitting right up
front here is the most wonderful woman
and the world has given me everything a
man could hope for her love and support
and the gift of our three treasures
Joseph Ava and Nicholas a dynamo of 13
months old Joseph is 6 and Avett just
turned 3 mom grace vicara is also
sitting up here mom there's nothing I
can say except I love you and thanks
very much mom stood up
I would also like to say a special hello
to my grandmother Ruth Ruth Ambrose
she's 91 years old she's watching on
television tonight from Hagerstown hi
Gigi and I would like to say hello to my
father Joseph and my grandfather Tony
who are someplace smiling I love you
they say that Washington is a town of
transients but our family has been here
for four generations helping to build
this city my grandfather was a cement
finisher and worked all around this town
my grandfather came from Spain and
waited tables and hotel ballrooms like
this during the Depression to put food
on his table I am proud to be a part of
their heritage finally thank you to Tim
Russert Wendy Wilkinson and Brady
Daniels along with all of the dedicated
journalists who make NBC News a dream
place to work an incredible force for
truth that it is and now with absolutely
no further ado may I introduce the
current chairman and the man who's going
to run next year's dinner mr. Brian
Wilson of Fox News Brian
I won't take up much of your time
because I know what this evening is
really all about and you will get to it
in just a while I just want to say one
quick word about Mike McAra he's been a
wonderful guy to work with he has
allowed me to be at his side during
negotiations at the highest level on
your behalf and there is no journalist
in town I think who feels as
passionately about issues of access on
Capitol Hill he has been a real friend
of all of you who work on Capitol
everyday covering this institution and I
would like to have a round of applause
for Michael McCary
and we will continue to work on issues
that are important to this organization
we will be talking about issues of
access we're in the middle of
negotiations now with leader frist and
others and in a few days you will
receive an email for me well you will
get all the details about what we're
working on and I ask you to take just a
moment to read that email when it comes
your direction now one piece of business
everybody please remain seated as the
vice-president and miss Chaney depart
the chamber
thank you everyone and good night